the Joe Rogan experience you know
rumbles not fighting but yeah that's a
dangerous fight if you want to keep your
knees like Craig Jones is no goddamn
joke Craig Jones is a heel hook and
[ __ ] he is it really yeah Craig
Jones is at the top of the food chain in
the submission grappling world but he's
not as big as Rumble but I don't think
anybody's drug-testing but that means
they're not drug-testing Rumble so who
know I don't even know if they have to
weigh in I don't think they're calling
it like David versus Goliath match so I
don't know yet the weight 50 pound
wonder what rumbles gonna weigh cuz
Craig Jones has been grappling I want to
I want to say he's probably around 215
220 long guy he's not not incredibly
ripped but this submission grappling
world is very strange because there's no
real drug testing to speak of and
everybody kind of knows that everybody's
kind of juiced up you know Brazil from
Australia yeah but I don't know I don't
think it comes that much into playing
and grappling you know so much technique
and leverage a ball that it comes and
you play it helps you track the train
much longer so much harder especially
with nogi probably does you know I think
in in noogie well I think it works with
g2 it's just look it's physical it's a
physical thing you get two guys one guys
on juice one guy doesn't the guy who's
on juice has some sort of an advantage
if they're both technically similar but
that's a tough fight for Rumble in that
Craig is used to being on the bottom and
he's used to fighting with with inside
control of the legs like I don't know
what kind of rumble would kind of leg
lock game Rumble has it is almond
shudders oh yeah the crazy thing is
Dennis home and went for a [ __ ] heel
hook here and Craig Jones is like nope
yeah not a good idea a good idea yeah I
feel like that's gonna be the next
little evolution that you see in MMA
it's like leg locks yeah
I've really like started to incorporate
it a little bit into into my game yeah
it's it's a especially against wrestlers
like I would be a little worried if I
was a in rubbles corner for that because
wrestlers a little more susceptible to
leg locks for sure so I feel like that's
gonna be like the next little level that
you see you have to understand the
system and I don't I'm not a leg lock I
it's hard yeah I see the transitions but
if I was on the mat with them I wouldn't
be a step ahead I wouldn't be able to
like know where they're going and I
would have to react as it's happening
which is a giant disadvantage and I
don't know what Rumble knows I know he
was a great wrestler and but rumbles big
thing was never submitting people's yes
locking people up standing up yeah I
mean I think the best way is just to try
and disengage from them and just not let
them hang your legs it's just that's
easier said doesn't look with all that
crazy on these just the thing with those
guys is when you're rolling with someone
who is that high level with submissions
you are reacting and they know how
you're going to react and they're
anticipating your reaction and they have
a counter to your reaction and you're
always one step behind so you can
explode and explode explode and
eventually you get a little tired then
who hoop and you know Hickson used to
talk about that it's like they can't
keep the rhythm as I always say they
can't keep the rhythm like this is
because they just keep going they keep
attacking and you just can explode and
explode and show everybody how athletic
you are but after a while that [ __ ]
wears out and then next thing you know
you're wrapped up in something yeah and
I think they see more guys like you you
know I mean they see more guys that are
just trying to to you know they see a
lot of wrestlers and a lot of guys just
try those same kind of defenses and
where you not seeing that many guys that
are good at late locks like that
especially to the point where now that
they're starting to understand it way
more technically then you know like
parkour is style of just like grab your
foot just trying to like squeeze the
[ __ ] off had some good technique but
complex it's like you know Eddie coming
sir yeah yeah I don't mean Pajaro said
general I just mean that style of doing
you know some guys you just see like
they just grab your foot and just twist
it the way it ain't supposed to go but
you know when you look at a guy like
Donna here style
and he's breaking it down like a mad
scientist he's like you know there's
literally gonna be no way that you're
gonna get out of those different levels
of it you know you've seen that with
Garrett Onan now and Emily yeah yeah
Gary tone was fighting over in one he
just submitted the [ __ ] out of somebody
with an inside deal it has he fought
against yeah he just fought real
recently Alec a week ago oh wow
Garrett Owens he's gonna be a world
champion I really believe that yeah I
seen his uh his first like to maybe well
he's undefeated he's foreign-owned now
okay and it's just the way he's winning
- he's [ __ ] people up and he's super
dedicated and he's just real smart and
when he's got with a guy like Danaher in
his corner
Danaher is another guy and he's also by
the way you know he's locked up with
Serrat frost ahah be they're all like in
cahoots together they train together but
Donna has got a special brain he really
does here's a special understanding of
submissions yeah I want to talk to that
guy yeah sure get on down New York yeah
yeah he's type of dude I said I thought
six hours would over like because he
seems like he's got that you know
systematic way of breaking stuff down
like that because it takes the guesswork
out of it uh-huh I mean it takes the
what if he does this oh I didn't he's
got an answer for it when he does this
he's got an answer yeah you know that's
why I feel like I'm kind of missing him
like what unnecessarily that in my game
but yeah I think that would be a great
addition to anybody's game yes to Train
down there and understand what that guys
doing or I mean there's a there's quite
a few different systems now and then
like you got like Craig Jones who's
coming like I said from Australia he's
got he's got a very similar system to
it's just everybody's got different
approaches to it but what Danaher did
and that hens Oh Gracie team did is they
just kind of like proof of concept like
just let everybody know hey like you're
missing out on a giant chunk of this
thing and a giant chunk of this thing is
all the variables that come into play
when guys are trying to rip each other's
knees apart yeah yeah it kind of goes
back to even like you know those
individual sports are so ahead of ours
awry you know like what we were talking
about earlier when you're seeing
world-class jiu-jitsu fighters or a
world-class
my Thai fighter they're just better at
that thing the other guys who do
everything yeah so I mean a couple years
ago you saw more like jujitsu go into
back attacks and you know arm bars were
like really big in it and now you then
they kind of went through like the leg
lock era and I feel like we kind of
stuck on the back attack kind of armbar
and eventually we'll move over to being
able to pull off leg locks because now
you see in a lot of jujitsu guys kind of
get away from leg lock and starting to
under the defense they're starting to
catch up a little bit I think it to go
to Worlds to see it but you know I'm I
always like to stay one step ahead of it
and see where it's going you know yeah
and what's on the other side